it's good for you to go through these
frustrations because one of the great
shortcomings of society is people have
lost their ability to be uncomfortable
so much of what you're seeing in today's
society is we've demonized the ability
to have
adversity discomfort in our bodies it's
really really nice to be with all of you
um obviously
you know given
the sheer size and scale of this
class
it really excites me
when you know when i think about how i
wanted to build the company
a couple years ago through
analyst class and then creators and pcs
and just everything we're doing
you know it's um it feels very rewarding
to
be in this moment with all of you the
amount of love
that this group has gotten
from individuals in this organization
has been extraordinary and um
i'm really uh grateful
i'm really proud of you thank you for
that
obviously some of you are better than
i'm just
and then so um
you know really what i want to do in
this time is bring you all the most
value i think one of the things i'm most
um
[Music]
proud of as a ceo is
i'm obsessed
would be the word i use
that
this decision to come into here at this
time is the best decision you've ever
made professionally and that may lead to
one of you sitting on this zoom right
now
ending up
doing what i do and ending up being the
global ceo of vayner x that is
potentially in the cards others
may leave in three months
but learn something during this time
that is foundational to what they do
javi what's good there you are great to
finally meet you such a pleasure
yeah i was wondering
knowing
knowing what you know now about the
industry about
you know the world in general and then
even like yourself um your growth as an
individual
what
would you tell your 25 year old self
knowing everything you know now
um
that
i would tell him
hey kid
you've got 90 of this figured out but
all the pain
and discomfort
and missteps that you're about to have
over the next 21 years
are going to be because you aren't good
at candor
that your lack of candor
is going to lead to
a lot of people loving you at all times
because you're making everything so
awesome but you're going to build
resentment
and that's going to manifest in personal
relationship vulnerabilities
and it's definitely going to manifest in
your passion to be a businessman because
you're not going to be able to give
people critical feedback
and then you're going to surprise them
when you fire them
and then instead of you
being
the good guy where you gave good
feedback and unfortunately didn't work
but you were gracious and you still did
the good severance and you were a good
person and you're good now you're going
to be a bad guy to some of these people
because on thursday you said hey hobby
keep crushing it and then on monday you
walk in and be like hi this is your last
day and he's like what the [ __ ] you said
last thursday everything was rolling
my obsession for happiness and like good
skewed too far
and i didn't have the balance of candor
it's why kind candor was invented it's
why it's foundational here and let there
be no confusion to everybody here
the
establishment of kind candor has helped
our company quite a bit over the last
two three years a lot
it has really helped us
and it's really helped me personally you
know
um
and so
uh that's what i would tell him my
friend
thank you
hi gary thanks for talking to us
of course
um if you had to distill the role of the
pcs into what into one function what
would it be
knowing everything that's going on in
culture at this exact second
i'm obsessed grace with the pcs
i would argue the pcs
at its core is the thing that's closest
to me who i am
it's scary how much [ __ ] i know
and it's by being super wide and then
being strategic when i go deep
and everything in between
right
like it's you know
it's
knowing why
slime was hot with nine-year-old girls
for 24 months it's knowing why polo g
could be the next drake
but with a little more hood it's by
knowing that why facebook
written words are working on fan page
it's like [ __ ] just knowing
you know what i mean curiosity at scale
grinding at scale
not imposing your own opinions
on [ __ ]
at scale which is impossible in this
highly charged political climate
it's being like a
like neutral vessel of curiosity
and then having the talent to convert
signals
into hypotheses
thank you
welcome
kevin
hey gary uh great to meet you
um just
just a quick question so we see with a
lot of these social platforms longer
form content becoming more prevalent um
and i was just wondering your thoughts
on how you see the actual ad space
changing as the type of content shifts
one more time brother it's something
[ __ ] uh chopped for me i i missed the
part right before more prevalent one
more time
so like as longer form content becomes
more prevalent on these short form
content um platforms how do you see
um the ad space changing within those
that's a great question i um
for me it hasn't changed much let me
explain what i mean by that think about
me i
i don't know if you guys know this this
is actually wild i've done a very bad
job branding this which is unusual for
me because i'm pretty good at personal
branding i
was legitimately no [ __ ] one of the
first 15 youtube celebrities
like in 2006 wine library tv it was like
zay frank rocket boom lonely girl
ronetto like i knew everybody who had
10
000 subscribers think about what i just
said to you
so
because of that um
uh
i've always known
that
the long-form ecosystem had legs that it
wasn't how long the video was
it's how good the video was
i was i actually got flown to yahoo and
google
because they had yahoo video on google
video before you google bought youtube
that was their product
and both those companies flew me out to
probe me
and asked me why people were watching 20
minutes of my videos and my answer was
literally i have no idea
i because i could you know at that point
i was a businessman the thought that i
had
on camera
charisma didn't even cross my mind
like it wasn't a function of like how i
all this notoriety and awareness and
micro fame i have now is so funny to me
i didn't
do anything public until i was 30
you know like it wasn't even the rate
it's not like you guys who grew up
knowing normal people could be famous
for me when i was 15 unlike you i
thought you had to want to be famous and
go to hollywood and wait tables and try
to be on television
so
here's how it's the reason vaynermedia
is going to be the biggest agency in the
world
what people don't realize is you have to
make content that people want to watch
and so the whole vayner video one bridge
one thing that i'm pushing that we
haven't really accomplished yet
is gonna be the whole game because
people will watch five minutes and 17
second videos
they're going to be
consumed at scale on streaming what do
you think netflix commercials are going
to look like
they're going to be there
and my intuition is people are going to
make shitty ones and my intuition is
vayner is going to make the best ones
and people going to actually like want
to watch our [ __ ]
like in between [ __ ] stranger things
we're going to make a nostalgic [ __ ]
video for [ __ ] casper and people like
what the [ __ ] was that because they're
not even gonna be sure if it's a
commercial part of [ __ ] stranger
things or like we're gonna confuse the
[ __ ] out of that
it starts in
sock and it builds up
and so i think that's how it's going to
go
awesome thank you so much gotcha
hey gary how you doing welcome first off
thank you for this opportunity um these
have been some of the best uh three
months of my professional life makes me
so happy grateful you know
um my question is has there ever been a
time in your life where you felt down
and out pressure on all sides and how
did you overcome that moment
i think my toughest times were
you know
in school
when
you know when you're 12 years old and 13
years old and
every teacher you have tells you that
you're going to be a loser and a garbage
man i don't know i feel bad like i was
so pissed that they would always [ __ ] on
garbage men and like i feel like that's
such a har like a job i respect so much
but that was the hot thing in the 80s
you're gonna be a garbage man i was like
oh [ __ ] you know i was like i was
actually kind of pumped i'm like oh [ __ ]
i can get stuff for free instead of
garage sales and flip it you know but
that was hard it was hard i think that's
why i'm unstoppable now because at 11 12
13 14
every grown-up i knew
teachers
and my friends parents
every grown-up i knew told me i was
going to be a loser
while
my mother told me i wasn't and
the world told me i wasn't
i was selling lemonade
shoveling snow selling baseball cards
flipping stuff at garage sales and i was
great at it the market told me i was
great
my mom told me i was great because i was
a nice person and here i am 46 years
later
a nice gangster businessman
but it was hard and uh and actually i've
never said this before it just hit me
and built a personal brand cause i can
deal with people [ __ ] on me because
they've been [ __ ] on me
of course you can't be a personal of
course people struggle putting
themselves out there they grew up as a
and b students
and like didn't don't haven't had that
emotional di you know adversity
thank yet so much appreciate you
appreciate you
mayor
hi gary thank you for this opportunity i
think it means the world to all of us
so for me you're the main resource for
enemies and most trusted person in the
world you can you actually took utility
to nfps and you brought the game into
another level
i want to know what do you think is a
limit for this industry because it's
totally new it's just been there for
years and i want to know the
future of that based on your ideas
you know the last year of nft land has
been really good to me i stood up the
property i've done well
but most of all i'm proud that i had the
strength to say that 99 of them were
gonna go to zero during the height of it
all
right i don't know how many guys and
gals follow this but like i was putting
out a ton of content saying 98 to 99 of
this is going to zero and i would always
confuse people because i was supposed to
be the poster child and the pied piper
and it would [ __ ] people up and i was
like well
yes but this is just the truth right
like you know to simon's point i liked
alien friends's art it went up to like
fifteen thousand dollars now it's like
100 like it's just the way it is it's
like sports card trading right like
yes michael jordan lebron went up but
like all that money i spent on chris
webber rookie cards i didn't make money
on that and chris webber had a great
career a borderline hall of fame career
and it still didn't work out so
you know the future but the reason i put
my reputation and my career on it
is
it is the biggest technology shift since
the internet
every single company and person will
interact with nfts they may not even be
called nfts the internet used to be
called the information super highway
the first four years i talked about the
internet i said the world wide web the
web
my website my my my dad's liquor store
is going to be on the web
now we say the internet i'm not even
sure we're going to use the word nft in
six years
but the concept of a blockchain at scale
affirming
neutrally
with no ability to cheat
transactions
is the biggest [ __ ] thing that's
happened since the internet and so i
think about it every day
i'm enjoying this downtime because it
lets me build v friends because i'm an
operator
and all the hysteria and the scams and
the greed of money money [ __ ] up
everything
money [ __ ] up everything for the people
that are [ __ ] up money doesn't [ __ ] up
everything for people that are good
money just exposes truth
and so there was a lot of great that
happened in the last year in nft and it
was a lot of [ __ ] that happened and but
what's the future you've heard me say
this i'm saying this for everybody else
every concert ticket every sporting
event ticket every plane ticket
every premium item you buy from lvmh
will come with an nft as a receipt
instead of a piece of paper or qr like
it's going to eat up paper and qr codes
and emails and apps and i can't wait
thank you sure thank you
ali
hey gary
just three weeks of visit london and i'm
loving it here and thanks for sharing
your good advice with us today
um
my question for you is
within the next six to eight months how
do you what are maybe five interesting
ways you see brands leveraging
nfts and how can a pcs
fit into that
the likelihood of a brand doing anything
in the next six to eight months is
almost zero
because the market is so bare they're
scared to be associated with something
that isn't winning
if they were smart
what they would do is lean into their
social good and non-profit
work that they're doing right now and
issue nfts for free
to the world that is collectible to the
best of their ability around their
ip and brand
and give the royalties
to their non-profits
that they have commitments to
that's the number one two three four and
five best thing they can do
let me teach you something that's really
smart about that
if they give away a million for free
and now they're
even selling for a hundred bucks with
five percent royalty the money starts
adding up right
but also they have a million people in
the world that have an nft sitting in
their wallet
so in a year or two they can say come to
this website and connect your wallet and
prove that you have this nft and get
free shipping for the year or get 20 off
or get access to our super bowl or world
cup or olympics party what they've
theoretically done
is they've seeded
a first party data pass
to consumers at scale
wow love that thank you
yeah they don't keep me around for my
looks it's this baby
yo sarah you laugh at that come on get
out of here why do you think or do you
think um
it's become more popular for people
to leave their jobs when they're unhappy
for a job that even has a lower salary
do you think
it has become more popular than it than
in the past saying in the 80s people
used to earn big big bucks but they're
you know they're not
happy do you think it's become more
socially acceptable for people to take a
paper but it helps their mental health
and their their life fulfillment do you
think
do you think that it has become more
popular and do you think there is a
correlation to where we are now
100
i think that
you
are more thoughtful
every generation is more thoughtful than
the prior one because you have the
luxury of the data
right you got to you know i we got to
watch the people who grew up in the 60s
and 70s and you got to watch the people
who grew up in the 80s 90s and 2000s
and there's more options there's more
information
you guys have no idea
i lived my entire childhood up until i
was 19 years old without the internet
think about that
so in the 80s finding a new job
was looking in the classifieds in a
newspaper
recruiters couldn't email you or hit you
up on linkedin
you have more options
and with more options comes better
decisions
and
more thoughtful conversations people
are becoming more thoughtful in my when
i was growing up to your point
make as much money as possible so you
can get a house and a car and a vacation
and now people are more minimalists
value
other things and i think it's a
beautiful thing
but i think it needs to be personal i
think a lot of kids struggle with being
very ambitious there's some kids that
hit me up and say like hey i feel out of
place with my gen zers i do want to work
15 hours a day i do want to build an
empire i'm like that's good too i i go
so hard
but when i say work hard
i don't say work hard and burn out
people are making assumptions out here
they they took a word i used to love
called hustle which meant work hard like
it matters
and we've manipulated it into this world
of like oh if you do that you're you
you're doing drugs and alcohol and have
mental health issues that's crazy
i'm the most chill calm person on earth
i'm so content and happy i'm chill as
[ __ ] i sleep seven eight nine hours a
day
i'm calm as a cucumber that's because
i'm in my zone and my zone is to be a
[ __ ] entrepreneur operator
uh for people that aren't they shouldn't
because it's [ __ ] anxious
you know like if i was a if i was my
admin my incredible admins i'd be
anxious
i don't like getting everything right
and making sure everything's running on
time i'd be fired in project management
within a week at vaynermedia a week
i um
or maybe i would quit in 48 hours
so
i think yes no question
but i think it's because we're trying to
be more self-aware
what we have to be careful of is what
i'm also seeing which is amazing all
that the one thing to watch out for
is entitlement
the one thing that i see creeping as a
cousin to a lot of this thoughtfulness
with a lot of youngsters is
staggering levels of entitlement
like
i should be the vice president of the
company i'm like you've been here three
weeks
and so the over coddling and and
delusional positive reinforcement of
modern parenting has confused a lot of
people
and
that's one thing that's a watch out and
by the way i hate when people like oh
gen z all millennials no 80 of you i
don't see it in but 20 is a lot because
it used to be one percent
like everybody in the 80s and 90s were
like i'm gonna give coffee to my boss
for five years then i'm gonna do this
then i'm gonna do that
now kids are rolling in at 20 and being
like yo
where's the corner office at
so what that's a watch out
[Music]
thanks gary
[Music]